add a Karen come up to me after the show
yeah and she got all up in my face and
she goes you know that story you told
about the Uber driver was racist and I
said what part about that was racist she
goes how do you know he was Mexican
and I said um
I'll tell you how I know he was Mexican
Karen
he had a portrait of the Last Supper
airbrushed on his tailgate
that's out of [__] I know he was Mexican
Karen
coming at the wrong one Karen
I happen to be a fan of airbrush
tailgates
and only Mexicans are keeping them alive
and I would simply like to say gracias
okay
I live right here too I've seen some
beautiful Jesus pieces in traffic all
around Southern California so maybe
you're the racist Karen clearly you've
never been to San Bernardino
foreign
[Applause]
hey guys I just want to say thank you so
much my special Lefty son is out and we
are at the time of this recording we're
already over 300 000 views so thank you
so much I appreciate all your support if
you haven't watched it yet I promise you
it's a great watch
um I directed this thing I produced it I
put a lot of time into this thing I was
in the hospital dying and still making
notes on it so go watch it if you
haven't yet share it like it comment on
it get it out there in that algorithm go
support Lefty son it's available my
YouTube now and it is free thank you for
your support
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night past
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media Ryan sickler thanking you
for watching this show thank you for
supporting this show thank you for
commenting on this show
um if you love it hit that subscribe
it's also a free way to help the show
all right and if you've got to have more
then you gotta check out the patreon
it's called the Honeydew with y'all I
talk about it every week I'm gonna
continue to talk about it every week
because I love my [__] job and these
stories
I'm telling you every week I say what
are we going to hear now and every week
I'm like holy [__] [__] because you
all have the wildest stories I've ever
heard in my life and I've heard a lot of
[__] okay so for five bucks a month you
get the entire catalog you get audio you
get video you get the Honeydew a day
early you get it ad free you get it at
no additional cost if you sign up for a
year you get almost a month free of
episodes all right it's honestly it's I
know 60 bucks a year is a lot for people
so if you've got the money trust me it's
worth it go check it out all right if
you're looking for a new podcast yeah
I'm promoting an old podcast it's called
The Crab Feast it's Audio Only it's a
storytelling podcast uh and it's
fantastic I'm telling you every every
comic you love that's in podcasting now
is on those episodes It's a seven plus
year Library take you forever to rip
through it it's good fun go check it out
all right now you guys know we do over
here we highlight the low lights the I
always say these are the stories behind
storytellers I am very excited to
welcome this guest first time here on
the Honeydew ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome Chase O'Donnell welcome to the
Honeydew Chase thank you you thank you
for being here thank you so much for
having me yeah you're a pleasant energy
already you came up you got good energy
good
um I'm very excited to talk to you but
before we do please plug and promote
everything Chase O'Donnell all of it
okay uh Instagram is really where
everything is Chase underscore O'Donnell
listen if you don't follow
Chase on Instagram you have to your [__]
is like Ryan the extra I watch all of
them the the actual like musical in real
life [__] like I'm scared I have anxiety
for you that someone's gonna like hurt
you when you're singing next to them on
a bus or a Subway or something I always
like God please don't hurt her I
sometimes drink alcohol before doing
this but I I I'm just like and I
wouldn't blame you you gotta work up I
can't believe you like them oh I love
you yeah I watch all of them you and who
was the the older man you just did one
with Kevin Chamberlain yeah that was a
great he's like a big Broadway guy and
reached out and I was like oh my god
really see that's how ignorant I am I
have no idea I'm at 10 million Tick Tock
followers
huge huge Broadway Tony nominated yeah
who's that guy oh who's that old fart in
that video with you oh but yeah they're
very scary but fun they look scary yeah
and they look fun like every time like
oh [__] yeah like because I like to
watch where you're gonna go I'm like oh
here's a great setup and where's this
[__] punch line I just did one in a
golf course and golfers are scared yeah
they're real [__] because I had to
like run out like in between their like
shots to make sure I wasn't gonna get
hit with a golf ball so sometimes I risk
my life for for the comedy yeah all
right
um so check out Chase underscore
O'Donnell
um and then my special people pleaser
just came out and that's on YouTube and
um would love do I look here I'd love
you to watch it
that's it Chase o'donnell.com there you
go yeah
all right and are you out on tour you're
on tour you go out with Christina
Christina I have my own dates they're
all on Chase o'donnell.com
I'm doing UC Santa Barbara this weekend
but that's for college kids that's fun
Santa Barbara is a fun town I've done
comedy up there a bunch that's where I
went to school I'm done UC Santa Barbara
we had I did a show there with Sam
tripley and we had a lady take a shoe
off and throw it at us what
well then there was an exit door right
here so I took her shoe and I opened the
exit door and I just kept that
[__] I thought it was like you
know I thought it was a relay and I just
threw her [__] shoes I was like
now I don't know
okay well hopefully they like me and
don't yeah sure you're a people pleaser
I am yeah I do I try really hard but see
that's I it's something I really do want
to talk about so
um I do know a little background on you
only because I'm friends with Christina
and stuff and I've sort of put things
together and Kirsten's told me things
but you Christina worked for your dad
that's how you met Christina before we
started recording you were saying she
was really someone you looked up to and
and someone who's certainly taking you
under her Wing especially in the world
of [__] comedy yeah but um you didn't
always grow up in the world of Comedy so
to speak so no you're you're local right
yeah I'm I grew up in Agora do you know
the valley I know
um
I I grew up dancing that was my mom was
my dance teacher and
um I like lived at our dance studio I
was there every day after school three
to like 10 p.m I'm going today to see my
daughter you watch she dances she just
started and I haven't I've been in the
hospital and missed her first too and
it's made me so sad so today's the first
one I get to go watch is it ballet she's
doing it's ballet and tap oh my two
favorites
oh my gosh
um
so good I think Dance Like Trains like
it teaches you such discipline and I
know sports do the same thing but all I
know is dance and I'm so grateful that I
had Dance Training so I'm glad you
played no I like that discipline Sports
to me more importantly than discipline
was also camaraderie and teammates
teammates and learning how to work well
with others things like that dance and
comedy unless you're in a group they're
so
discipline if you're going [__] for
it for real yeah you better be
disciplined and you have to really learn
how to love yourself
when you're bombing yeah you already
hate yourself
it starts with that's a journey
um but I'm still me
I'm just figuring it out I'm like you
guys are talking about a fork in a row
when I got there there were like seven
different ways to go and I think I
picked three of the wrong ones you know
so oh yeah there's like a million
different ways yeah
anyways dance was my my Escape Escape
but also just like all I did it was my
life
um I didn't necessarily choose it I was
just put into it because that's my mom
was a dance teacher so we went to dance
and did you love it
yeah yeah I did or did you grow to love
it
I always am like if I had chose if I got
to choose a sport
um because my parents might put my older
sister into like soccer karate
gymnastics diving like she did like
everything and then picked dance so I
just was thrown into dance I often
wonder is that what I would have picked
but I'm so glad that I did I think I you
use it on the gram non-stop yeah I and
I'm I'm like I don't say this about any
other thing in my life but I know I'm
really good at dancing because I have
just like so much training it's
unbelievable and just a lot of time
performing it was always nutcrackers and
recitals and dance competitions and
whatever it was I just like my life from
Age 2 to 18 was on the stage so I have
two questions do you ever just like
[__] hit a spin around the house or
something like that for yourself of
course
you should see me going on walks because
I listen to music and I have to go is
anyone watching and then I'll like
I'll start dancing yeah
um tell me real quick are what are the
dance moms and dads like are they just
as aggressive as the the sports parents
oh oh or pageant Mom I thought you were
gonna say have you ever seen the show
Dance Moms no
well that's what it's like um check out
the show uh I don't know what sports
parents are like I've I've never
actually told me he yelled at a ref and
they had to like kick him out in front
of everybody in the basketball court I'm
like why are you yelling like that he's
like because the guy sucked yeah he said
don't worry I'll leave I'm tired of
watching you blow calls all night it's a
little different because you can't be
like doing a valet piece and the moms
aren't like go get them girl
so it's not like that
but there are pushy stage moms dads yeah
you get the stage stage parents and
dance
and then you get some really chill
parents that are like whatever
so so growing up here you get into dance
dance is all you do
all I do until uh
it was around
uh High School ninth grade that High
School Musical
the Disney Channel original film came
out did you watch it no okay but I know
it very well I know it's huge huge
success for the Disney Channel
um and I was like oh that's what I want
to do with my life and I was like I'm
gonna be uh not just a dancer but like
an actor and singer and do it all and I
told my parents like I want to get me
into auditions right now okay and they
were like absolutely not they would not
let me audition and try which is in
hindsight very good uh child actors
don't have the best
in lives
um but they were very supportive of like
if that's what you really want then go
take class and they put me into acting
classes and I went to
a performing arts high school and I then
like in college majored in theater and I
just it's been a lot of like training to
get there to get the comedy to get to go
like literally I don't know of any other
parents like all right that's what you
want to do GO train so I have so much
just like dance training acting singing
theater Shakespeare checkup like I just
am so
I dove so deep into it but I didn't like
go do it I just trained for a long long
time so how does things shift in high
school
in which way well you and I talked
earlier about this being high school is
rough for me yeah so I went to two high
schools
um ninth and 10th grade was Agora High
which
miserable and then 11th 12th grade
things got a little better when I went
to the performing arts high school but
Agora High
was so tough personally because like I
said I was like obsessed with High
School Musical I was obsessed with
Disney Channel I like my role models
were Zach and Cody from The Suite Life
of Zack and Cody and Hannah Montana and
all the kids I was going to school with
were watching like the OC and
um the simple life and like I see and
and Agora is like right next to
Calabasas this is like the Kardashian
type people I was going to school with
and I just felt so
different and I wasn't like into
partying and I was I just was
I would go to my dance studio and dance
and then go to school and be like oh I
don't fit in here
and
the the tough part I think was that I
just
because my role models were these Disney
Channel kids
I didn't know anything
like one kid was like Hey Chase do you
party
and I remember being just like really
offended and I was like yes but I
thought he was talking about birthday
parties you really did like I really I
didn't know there was another type of
party that you could go to
um
I didn't know and then and I talk about
I have a lot of jokes about this from
high school because I like I I wore this
shirt all the time that had 69 on it
but I didn't know Brian but it was a
thing your mom and dad never said
anything they do I think my parents were
like we gotta make her a little cool
like I think they knew okay but I've
talked to my mom about it and was like
why did you do this she's like I don't
know I thought it's fun like she really
didn't she didn't know the kids wear it
um and kids would be like do you know
what that means and they'd be like yeah
and I've learned I'm I've learned never
to say you know what something means
when you don't because people will
follow up
um
and I would get like just so humiliated
because I didn't know what anything
meant and uh
and then I just like
I just
I'm thinking of a story I was
I always got detention because I was in
can you believe no after you see my eyes
I know and you said always not I'd be I
wouldn't be surprised at one time I'm
not getting detention for I was in zero
period so that I could get out at 12 to
go to dance
and zero periods started at six a.m I
know so I have to I had to be up at like
5 a.m I'd be getting home at like 10 p.m
period anyways at home room like is that
where you just check in to make sure
you're in the building and then you go
to college it's like some people could
choose to start school at six to get off
at 12. but whereas everyone else started
with first period at like whatever time
eight
7 30. so I was late every day and I just
built up all these detentions
and I uh I had to go to Saturday
detention with where all the cool kids
go and I couldn't go because I had
Nutcracker rehearsal and my mom walked
me in with my ballet clothes and she's
like gets me out of detention in ninth
grade
10th grade
in your ballet I'm in ballet clothes
Saturday
and I
I go to the other side of the room and
then she goes come on Chase let's go got
you out of detention in front of all the
kids I'm already not cool and I had to
like be like okay and I leave and then
the school didn't know what to do with
me because I had all these detentions
and I couldn't do Saturday detention so
they made up a detention just for me
that no one at Agora High knew was
detention
and I was just driving around with the
janitor after school
three months
talking about after school where is he
going he should be on the property I
mean the janitor would drive around in
his garden and clean up the school and
the kids thought I was friends with the
janitor no one knew it but did that give
you cool points or were you extra door
keeper okay like waved in the golf cart
like just because I didn't know what to
do and kids wouldn't wave back like I
just remember being like Chase don't
wave parade wave if you do though yeah
like parade wave if you do parade wave
it was so humiliating
um but I got through that phase what was
his name I don't remember how do you not
remember you spent three months with
this I know I don't think I really
talked to him I think I was like so
embarrassed he didn't chat you up no and
I think he's like who's this girl like
why does she have to come around with
attention too
golf cart with me I want to know who the
[__] thought of that and somebody was
like that's a good idea send her out
there with Larry let her clean up know
what to do with me
and like literally because it wasn't a
real detention like nobody understood
what I was doing after school with the
janitor some
I would pretend I was Hannah Montana and
I would be like these kids they just
they don't know after school I'm a rock
star and they wish
they were my friend I I like really
channeled Disney Channel like it was my
savior in high school okay
so
I wanted to be homeschooled really
really really really really bad I would
cry most days after school I was just so
I just didn't
fit in would you say you were being
bullied or were you just more being
embarrassed of the way the differences
in your growing up and they're growing
up I don't know there was like there's
mean girls that like
like if I wore a shirt that was like I
love rock and roll they'd be like do you
love rock and roll name three bands like
just mean stuff
and so is that bullying one time you
know I mean they would say today it is
but I just feel like that's [__]
normal [__] okay I told this story one
time and I didn't think it was bullying
and then someone was like yes this is
bullying let's see okay I didn't know
what a dildo was I I Can Only Imagine
and some guy in class was like oh the
teacher had a dildo and I was like no
way
and then like you don't know what that
is do you and I was like yes and they're
like what and then I had to be like I
don't know so they like tell me what it
is and then for like probably three or
four weeks these guys would follow me
around campus going Z like making
vibrating noises
is that bullying did they call you dildo
hey dildo or are you were you dildo for
three weeks as a nickname cause if yes
then I would say yes it's bullying if
they walk behind him buzzed I I don't
know if that's just being an [__] or
bullying but it stops
and then
what okay their batteries ran out
because I'd pretend like I didn't hear
them you ignored them and they went away
but I I never got called dildo I got
called puke face
why
and this was at my new high school oh no
wait can I ask you a question real quick
we're going to come back to puke face
okay did you ever connect with another
person like you didn't find one soul in
that whole school okay I had one of my
best friend to this day from the first
school yeah she and I went to the same
dance studio and we like had each other
okay good in high school so one of the
terrible things at least you got your
best friend out of it oh yeah and we
like we cry laughing talking about high
school because of the humiliation we
both went through was she like the same
way like would you run away Joe like
what's a Dodo I don't know I called her
I immediately called her as like you
have to know what a dildo is because if
this happens to you
you have to be prepared and so like we
would help each other out and we also
like we got invited to a real party and
there were
um there's drinking going on and we were
like what drinking and we a lot of it
was me just pretending to be cool
because I would always be like yeah I
know what 69 is yeah I do so I I put
both of us put water in the cup and we
were like walking around with water and
everyone was like you guys drink and
we're like yeah
um so I had her to go through that with
puke face happened uh we moved it was
like 2007 the recession time
and um did you both go to the same
school were you devastated that you were
gonna have your best friend in high
school anymore it was devastated okay
but we were both like
I knew I was lucky because I got to
start over
it was actually more exciting for me
getting to go somewhere else because
this is a actual art school right okay
um but it's hard switching as a junior
yeah you're in the middle of everything
well I was gonna say no offense usually
you have your friends sorry you said up
I only had one friend
I had a lot of friends at my dance
studio usually you play sports or
whatever you got your friends to dance
studio yeah yeah
buddy yeah my parents I was like can I
just be homeschooled but anyways OSHA
was great I listened to the episode with
Jody Sweden yeah is I went to the same
high school she did okay I didn't know
that she went there anyways
good performing arts high school and all
of a sudden I found other
high schoolers that were also into like
musicals and Disney Channel and like I
found my people there
but
I was still very
naive
um for high school
um anyways my senior year my sister was
in college and my sister's really cool
I should mention that
um she was like Chase like you got to
drink you have to drink it's weird that
you don't and I was like oh okay and
I'll do what she tells me and
she was like you can have like five
shots oh my God
that's a lot and I was like okay no
offense your size probably even smaller
it's tinier like smaller frame
everything and five shots is a lot I
know I it's I mean I didn't know but I
was like now I know so and she's like
teaching me drinking games so it was
like the first party of senior year and
I was like I'm ready and I took five
shots just one two three four five
you didn't space him out over the night
she clearly didn't teach me how drinking
worked because what was it what did you
have do you remember tequila oh boy oh
boy and people are cheering me on
they're like oh my God Chase drinks now
and I was like yeah I do like who's
welcome yeah this Earth to whoever I've
drank now and then
um it was like probably a minute later
because I took it all very fast and I
was like I don't get it like how does
this work I was like I can give me five
more and I took 10 shots no within like
five minutes you did not the first time
I ever drank 10
you thought five was bad yeah I did I
took ten you doubled down on that [__]
yeah I was like I can do give me another
round of five
this didn't work and I
I
truly I blacked out you have to I
remember
sitting down at a couch and then I woke
up the next day at the house just
covered and throw up your house oh same
house at OSHA it's like a commuter
school people from all over Orange
County go there so whenever there was a
party there were sleepovers like
everyone just stayed at the house
um so I woke up at the house and I yeah
I was covered in throw up and I was like
that's weird I had no idea what happened
and I didn't think anything happened and
then I I walked out people were having
breakfast they're like you had a fun
night
I found out that I had been throwing up
the whole night just like in people's
purses oh no like on myself in the
closet just all I was doing was throwing
up for like the entire entire night and
so I went to school on Monday when I
walked into class the whole class
applauded
kind of like wow she's alive
and I was like I was gonna say alcohol
poisoning I think I should have gone to
the hospital 10 shots and nonsense
growing up yeah
and then I got called puke face for a
long time
and I remember I was like on a field
trip and no one sat next to me because
they're like we don't want to see an
extra puke face yeah is that bullying
yeah that is okay I got bullied you
definitely got bullied for sure yeah
yeah this is I mean that's it's right
there I feel like that's also like older
sibling type [__] too you know what I
mean like yeah but I'm Different I know
some people say that is bullying someone
you said somebody said that's bullying I
guess
I guess yeah I never thought of it as
bullying but I just thought because I
never got like punched or like you know
what I mean yeah that's what I thought
me too originally me too like I'm not
touching you or hurting you it's just
because we were always taught the stupid
[__]
um what is it names will never hurt me
all that [__] you know sticks and stones
will break my bones my name's not it was
like who cares they're just words that's
what we were always taught if someone
says something at school just ignore it
whatever yeah that's what we were taught
even a stranger your brother or whatever
just who gives a [__] what they say
don't let them bug you yeah and then we
wouldn't you know or at least if we did
you got punched and they were like what
happened I'm like you know it was Sticks
and Stones today [__] yeah
yeah so
um
same thing happened my sister in college
uh told me to eat a weed brownie
how many she tell you to eat now well
she told me to eat half of a weed
brownie and I did and then I blacked out
at Six Flags I was on a date it was a
date party
and I passed out let's jump back to that
real quick
what is a date party I've ever remember
you weren't in the Greek system
um
I wasn't okay by the way in college I
was really cool by college where'd you
go to school you see Santa Barbara all
right oh yeah you just said you were
performing yeah um
oh my God that was so cool in college so
I was in a sorority and there were like
uh date parties or a thing you like go
on you you invite a date and then you go
somewhere fun and like what like six or
seven couples or more oh like in a
sorority there's about 150 girls
oh [__] this is big yeah huge party and
this one just happened to be to Six
Flags
and my date was like we should take a
weed brownie
I was like let me call my cool sister
who like knows this stuff and she was
like take half you'll be fine and I
literally I passed out I was on a roller
coaster and was kind of like blacking
out and then and then I was like I need
to sit down I and I I was literally in
the food court
for the whole date party and my poor
date
so my sister has led me astray two times
really poorly yeah
yeah I now don't listen to what she's
saying we're not listening to cool older
sister yeah older sister I can't listen
to her anymore stay cool over there
there's no quick fix for anxiety and
depression it's not finding a new
therapist or starting an exercise
routine it's not more in regular
meditation or a better diet sometimes
you need something to unlock your brain
a new way of thinking about and seeing
the world maybe that thing is guided
ketamine therapy for mind Bloom there's
a new tool to improve your mental health
it's at home ketamine therapy mind Bloom
is the leader in at home ketamine
therapy having safely helped thousands
of people overcome their anxiety and
depression unlike traditional talk
therapy ketamine Works quickly and
doesn't have the unpleasant side effects
of traditional antidepressants and a
study of over 1 200 mind Bloom clients
89 reported improvements in their
anxiety and depression after only two
sessions right now mind Bloom is
offering my listeners 100 bucks off your
first six session program when you sign
up at mindbloom.com Honeydew and you use
the promo code honeydew take the first
step and break free from your anxiety
and depression with mind Bloom
mindbloom.com honeydew and use promo
code honeydew buying tickets to your
favorite events should not be stressful
game time is the fast and easy way to
buy tickets for all the sports music
comedy and theater near you with killer
deals on last minute tickets and their
best price guarantee you can stop
stressing over the tickets and start
getting excited for the fun you'll have
the game time app makes it insanely easy
to buy tickets for any event in your
area once you open the app you can sort
by popular events in your area by event
type whether it's sport music or shows
you can do it by the venue and they even
have the category of events under 50
bucks so you can find something that
fits your budget it's the fastest
growing ticket app in the country for a
reason forget planning months in advance
game time has deals on tickets right up
to the day of the event you can get
exclusive Flash Deals on tickets for
football basketball baseball concerts
comedy theater and more I just used it
we just all went to the Kings game we
used the game time at the game time
guarantee means you'll always get the
best price if you find the tickets in
the same section and row for Less game
time will credit you 110 of the
difference snag the tickets without the
stress with Game Time download the game
time app create an account and use code
honeydew for twenty dollars off your
first purchase terms apply again create
an account and redeem code honeydew for
twenty dollars off download game time
today last minute tickets lowest price
guarantee now let's get back to the Duke
anyways I jumped ahead to college but
that's so the gist of high school let's
go to college then so are you but are
you still dancing and performing in high
school yeah so at OSHA
um you like major in high school so I
majored in theater and still was like
taking dance but doing all the like
musicals and that too was like you go to
school till three and then you have your
Conservatory classes till five and then
you have rehearsal till 10. this is very
um when I listen to it structure wise it
sounds very almost like the way people
apply religion to their lives too you
know what I mean going to school I'm
going here after school and then I'm
going to mass in the evening I'm gonna
go home and I do it again it's just
interesting that dance was that for you
yeah I mean like it's school I'm doing
dance and performance I'm going here and
then I'm going to this day now this
dance this after school dance chance
that your mom teaches do they also have
plays and performances so are you
performing in the community so to speak
with this group and then also doing
things in school performances in school
too no because when I moved we moved
away we moved to Orange County so I
wasn't way away yeah I was no longer in
the same dance studio and yeah so I just
was doing the Performing Arts High
School
so
um and did you want to go to college for
that as well yeah you did I didn't
really want to go to college I wanted to
just go straight into acting but again
my parents were like no you're going to
college
um
so yeah it was just a ton of rehearsals
and I I think that's why I mean I never
got into
drinking or drugs or anything because I
was so focused I definitely had like
this is what I'm doing
and so what do you what do you major in
college
so I went to college for theater okay
and dance so the same two things yeah um
really smart choices for um I now have a
lot of student debt for theater and
dance
um and yeah same thing like I always
felt like when I was in college my
friends were majoring in like
Communications or this and they never
went to class because they were like all
lectures didn't matter but in the
theater program there were only 11 of us
so you had to show up and then
and then I was in the play every
whole College 11 of you yeah well it was
a cut system so you had to like keep
passing oh [__] okay so this was and
then I kept honestly trying not to get
cast in plays because when you're cast
you then you have rehearsals every night
like six to ten so it's the same thing
um but I was in a play every quarter of
all four years so I just like constantly
I was just I really studied theater and
then I would like run home and go to a
party and then like wake up and go to
8am ballet so it was just it was very
rigorous for theater and dance
and then you get out of college and what
do you do with that degree
okay I mean I don't know
um I
I
was auditioning while I was in college
um
and one thing I got my C senior year or
junior year my dance teacher growing up
was really good friends with JC chaise
from NSYNC yeah yeah
okay
and JC was starting a girl group
and my dance teacher was casting it so I
didn't mean to be in a girl group but I
got cast in a like I got I got I was
part of a girl group that JC started are
you being serious you really were I
really was what's the group girl radical
good for you for you you made it yeah I
was like I this you wanted this yeah
here it is oh my God it was like a dream
come true I was Chase radical oh no
y'all had radicals Spice Girls
but get ready they're most groups are
like five
there were 12 of us so they were trying
to do like the super K-pop groups that
have like oh yeah and they were trying
to bring that to America
and it was interesting because like I
was still in college and we would go
record and I would drive out to LA and
like we never sang together we all would
go in one at a time do our little part
and then like it's not we never
rehearsed we never like were together as
a group it's all very manufactured yeah
together yeah and then
um
so you never saw the other girls or
anything in the group I did
um they tried to make a reality show out
of it so they did like a
a weekend of taping where we were all
together and they wanted to start drama
they would like ask us who's your least
favorite in the group okay now go
confront them like they were trying to
make a whole thing out of it
um so as you can imagine
lots of drama in the group
um
and then America's Got Talent
reached out and was like we'd love you
guys to
perform on the show like audition girl
radicals gonna perform okay which like I
said we've never we had never done like
um stuff together never no not one live
performance
no okay
so
um
we did it
and and can I ask you what do you do do
you do an original song do you do a
popular song
we did a cover of I'm Just a Girl by No
Doubt okay the problem is I'm Just a
Girl by No Doubt is kind of ironic and
she's saying like I'm just a girl like
she's like making fun of the fact girl
radical took it very literally and did
it like I'm just a girl and didn't
really get the irony
of the song
anyways is that JC directing that who
made that call I don't know what JC's
thinking so far
I was wearing jeans and a top but a lot
of the girls are in like booty shorts
and like oh you all didn't match you
didn't have a uniform or anything like
that no you're allowed to be
individually we were Radical yeah we
were like our own style
okay all right um
You said they're all there
yeah yeah so and here's the thing I I
I've never been pursuing
singing and uh like it wasn't
it wasn't like my first Passion so it
was kind of just like I was in the
background I got I got in the group more
for my dancing and then I was just like
a little
backup chorus girl whatever so
I'm just saying that because we've got
on stage and within 18 seconds we were
axed
who's counting though 18 seconds 18
seconds so you know you get axed but you
can't stop until you get axed by
everyone so you have to keep going
and then we're dancing and we start
getting booed bye 3 000 people that's a
lot of fun have you been booed by 3 000
okay no
I performed in front of three thousand
but they didn't all do yeah they did
then I'll tell you what if they did it
would be something else it would often
say I do think that's a lot of booze
coming out everyone should be booed by 3
000 people
just to you know but you're in a you're
in the comfort of 11 others imagine that
just for you well exactly I'm so lucky
it wasn't for stand up because I
probably would have just stopped
everything for the rest of my life
everything I was lucky that it was oh
I'd be scared we've never done anything
people boo me getting the mail
you suck at getting that mailman oh my
God damn everyone
um so yeah I'm very lucky it was with 12
people
and then the judges like you know it's
it's Heidi Klum and Howie mandelier
um Osborne then no a Scary Spice scare
oh and you guys are up there doing a
sort of a spice girl-ish thing oh and no
one had any good things to say and every
time a judge was like I don't get it the
crowd would be like what like they would
cheer when the judges would talk bad
about us so a very humbling experience
but I feel like that's a low light to
live through I don't think a lot of
people know have experienced that that
level of Shame no public not only are
you getting booed by 3 000 people it's a
lot of people right there but now it's
also on television every Tuesday every
Tuesday it was like oh my God is this
the day it's gonna air and I would like
go hide and curl in a ball
they never aired it is that right
um there was some sort of suing that
happened or something there was a lot of
threats that if this came out
I don't know they somehow finagled it
because it would have been gold for TV
really amazing
um but the group broke up before we even
got off stage I think we were broken up
before we got off yeah I'm sure I think
we were already broken up
um and then
but I just have to say I love JC Chasez
with all my heart and I he came to my
special and like did he really so
supportive are we still supportive of
you oh that's actually very cool okay oh
my gosh it was the coolest experience to
like get to work with him and I I was
such a fan of in sync and like that
overall very cool experience but the the
getting booed on stage was a
a humbling one yeah that will ground you
yeah
um so he saw you get booed and then Saul
you get cheered yeah yeah you're special
that's awesome
I know he's been very supportive
um
anyways so that was like during college
and a little after and then
I got cast and I was auditioning like
immediately after college and I got cast
in an Off-Broadway Musical
so I just moved straight to New York and
I at what age are you I was 22. okay
and it was like literally living the
dream being a paid actor doing musical
theater in New York and
um that was amazing but then the show
got canceled and then I was like oh now
I'm a struggling actor living in New
York looking for work
and let me tell you
um
not fun I I in college the program at
UCSB is very much about creating your
own work so I left college with a
one-person show so I
um was just like okay I'm gonna create
my own work because I was auditioning
but it's just rejection after rejection
after rejection after it's just hundreds
of rejections and so that's it it is
and it's really like I look back at like
22 year old me and I was like I was
confident like I thought I was amazing
and everyone should cast me and like I
I'm ready and like by time I was 24 I
was extremely depressed so it only took
two years of just constant rejection to
see a huge difference in my like Mental
Health
but I
yeah I put on my one person show I
turned it into a two-person show with
one of my best friends in New York and
uh we did that it was called two blondes
and then was auditioning throughout it
um
also had like seven day jobs trying to
support myself and it's just have you
ever lived in New York you've always
been la oh yeah I was Baltimore uh
originally from Baltimore so I was over
the winter and [__] and I was like I
want to go yeah New York yeah only
because of the winter I also like La I
really do like it here it's slower paced
it's it's not that aggressive East Coast
um Pace it's much more laid back the
weather's [__] great
I agree but it took me living in New
York to be like oh I lived in the best
place in America drive too yeah I mean I
like to drive I didn't really Drive in
New York we have the air conditioning in
the car and it's sunny and like we have
the beach like it just is so much nicer
um and I hear people that live on the
east coast and move to New York have an
easier adjustment than people on the
west coast that move to New York that
would make sense to me West Coast going
east is harder than East going west yeah
yeah East going west you just let your
shoulders down after a little bit and
try to chill West go on East you better
put your [__] fists up and get ready
for him but you better be throwing up
for cuts and elbows out there yeah I'm
tired of throwing them I came out here
to relax yeah so I and I'm a very
sensitive as a Pisces very empathetic
very like walking down the street and
just seeing
homeless people everywhere and people
with signs like I have AIDS laying down
and like I just was constantly sad
for everyone around me and I it was just
really
taking a toll on just my
I just I guess the word is I was
depressed I was crying every day I was
walking in the streets crying definitely
even for us I was I I hated my the jobs
I was doing and that's when I realized
like even though I'm pursuing like
comedy
um oh I was also doing stand-up well
that's all I want to ask you when do you
switch that because
stand up is nothing like theater I mean
maybe you can find the parallels in it
but it's not that
um you know do these things and you go
here and do this it's just very much it
is I started stand up as soon as I
graduated college okay
um it was like okay I'm it's it's the
way to like always be in control of your
career and I had a lot of tools on how
to create my own work and so I felt like
stand-up was always a way to like get up
and perform and not have somebody
um tell you that you're allowed to so
yeah stand up I've been doing as soon as
I graduated but like you know at the
beginning you can have one really good
show and you're like oh I'm great and
then you bomb and you're and just like
the bombs are so
awful yeah
and I've I just had so many bombs where
people would be like who thought Chase
was never gonna get off the stage or
like just I I apologized one time after
a show because it went really bad and
the host was like
okay it's just this is a comedy show so
next time do comedy
so many bombs
and that one's stuck with you yeah I
mean so mean
um so all the while I mean just living
in New York is hard but just constantly
being rejected and and like questioning
why am I even doing this so that's my
question for you about comedy why are
you doing this because if that's getting
to you like that the only way to really
find out what's funny as you know is to
[__] bomb and make mistakes or be
like okay
either I'm not doing what I need to do
with this material or this just isn't
something I need to be pursuing like
that's the only way to go okay that
works that works that worked that work
you know how do you why do you stay with
comedy if the already being rejected for
acting and all these things is bothering
you and depressing you so much I don't
know the only way to succeed in comedy
is to keep bombing I it's like so crazy
to me it's because I decided when I was
like 14 I was like that's what I'm doing
like I'm gonna be
it wasn't like so much a comedian but I
knew I wanted to like do comedy
in some form so it's almost like I
didn't want to let down my younger self
and I had this even though like
I was sad it's like I had this knowing I
knew I was good and I had enough
validation throughout my life that I was
like
constantly getting praised and like
um in in growing up I knew that I was
good enough
so I like had that knowing always that I
was like I know I just need to figure it
out because
at for some reason I've had this
confidence of like I'm great
but that like kept getting
torn down oh yeah the world has a way of
doing that too but I still there was
still some part of me that was like no I
know I'm good I know I would watch
people and be like I'm so much better
than that and I guess that's the only
way I would like keep going
because I had so many friends that just
like
straight out of college they were
already working and never stopped and I
was like well isn't that lovely so I I
don't know I just
I did become very bitter
I became very sad
um but I feel like I'm saying this and
it seems like oh boo hoo you got sad
because things didn't go your way
which doesn't sound good but I was just
very unhappy well depressions you know
it doesn't matter whether you're rich or
poor or you know what language you speak
depression is the depression when you're
there it doesn't matter how you [__]
got there yeah you got there from I mean
it's not easy if that's the job you take
imagine imagine trying to be a doctor or
something like that and every time you
go in to do a search or somebody like
you killed that guy you failed you
failed you failed you failed and then
one time you get it right here we go
here we go you know what I'm eating it
it doesn't exist it doesn't exist you're
just failing non-stop yeah and it was a
lot of
um I mean talking about people pleasing
that was like my 20s was people pleasing
where does that come from is that like
and also again but also let me say this
I know I asked you a question I'm
cutting you off but people pleasing
might also be the thing that saved you
because you wanted us you just said I
didn't want to let my 14 your old self
down and that [__] thing might be the
very thing that was like I'm not gonna
let that girl down either so even though
we're about to talk about maybe it's a
detriment it also might be the very
thing that kept your fire going myself
yeah whoa so where does it come from
were you like always trying to make your
parents happy teachers happy like you
were always the good girl like I was
always an amazing student I I I always
wanted I guess I got continual praise
for like look I did what they wanted me
to do and I got praise for that so I
don't know exactly where it started from
but I didn't notice it until my 20s and
in my 20s I think the reason I hit such
a like
um rock bottom was because all of a
sudden I realized like I'm not
everything I'm doing is because somebody
told me to do this and someone told me
to do that and my agent wants me to do
this and that like I wasn't doing
anything I
I
like so I
I really was just
like just not living my life I was doing
the reason I had like seven jobs I
didn't need seven jobs
I did for the money but I could have
like found one job that worked for me I
someone would offer me something I'd be
like okay sure and like I was just
anything I would do it and I was so
tired and so just pulled in so many
directions and I wasn't focusing on like
the main goal which was comedy I was
doing a million other things besides
stand up so I just I think it took a
huge toll on me that I wasn't living for
myself
and I
got kicked out of my apartment in New
York
um so it was like Brooklyn was Bushwick
is has become very gentrified and in
2018 it was like starting that and they
like paid everyone in the building to
leave but we had to move
and me and my boyfriend broke up and he
broke up with me because I was crying
every day
which never again will I cry to a boy my
God
he said he turned into my therapist oh
so I mean I was it was really bad
um
so anyways I was like okay
I'm getting like pushed out of New York
like time to go and I took the like
little bit of money that they gave us to
move
um and I went to New Zealand and I spent
a month in New Zealand and then went to
Thailand and I had a little Eat Pray
Love okay because I knew I was like I
can't keep going on this
unhappy
um and did you go solo I went with my my
friend had just quit her job and was
going to New Zealand solo
and she was like come with me and I was
like okay I will so it worked out very
magically
um
and
it was just kind of my reset I called it
my quarter life crisis
because it was really
I was like 26 and I was just like this
this is a crisis like I also all my
friends that had done like normal jobs
um had gone into like nine to fives were
all
in such a different place in their lives
they like knew what they were doing and
what direction they were going and they
felt like they had stability and I just
was like I'm I don't have any stability
and um
so I went to New Zealand in Thailand and
then I came back and moved home and I
was like I'm done with this business I
am going to all I wanted to do was PA I
just wanted to PA I just wanted to
uh be behind the scenes but work on a
comedy show
because I was so over the
being in front of the camera and putting
myself out there and it was just so
draining
and I spent a year applying for PA jobs
very tough to get surprisingly yeah
um I am surprised yeah because once
you're in you're in but to get into that
Circle
um and I got a job on Curb Your
Enthusiasm
all right and I was like okay that's a
good one oh yeah okay good I was
thinking before I started great job good
thank God great job
I for some reason having never paid they
put me in charge of Larry David which no
I don't feel like I would feel like
Larry David would have a person at this
point that knew Larry David you know
what I mean Larry David should have
something he has a personal assistant
okay but I was the PA all right that had
to knock on his door tell him when it
was time to go to set walk him to set on
set keep eyes on him make sure he knew
what was going on like so he also had
someone that would like take care of his
like food and certain things
um
but like Dina Larry I don't know him
personally so
um he like doesn't feel the need to fill
a silence and I do feel the need to feel
as silence so we'd like walk to set and
he'd be like how's how's the traffic
Larry and he wouldn't respond at all no
because he doesn't need to respond he
doesn't who has time for that type of
small talk he's going to set and then I
would like
hum to myself or like I try to how long
is the Wall
that would have been like a seven minute
walk in silence that's a long time to
ask someone a question he doesn't answer
oh man I know I only have amazing things
to say about life that's a long time
yeah but
um I love it you said here's how you
know I don't know him you call him Larry
I call him Larry David okay I do not
know Larry David though I mean I have
Curb Your Enthusiasm Larry's stories I
don't know I don't know if we go into
them yeah tell me okay well I I am
did it did you ever break the ice at all
yeah
but he did
so yeah no like at the at the party the
wrap party it was like chase you know
like we we know each other he's very
sweet
um but he did ask the ads
um to tell me to stop stalking him no
stalking him because
as a PA I was supposed to know where he
was at all times he buys on them all and
professional Pas have been doing this a
long time are very good at just being
like okay he walked over to crafty okay
that's where he is I'm gonna stay put I
didn't know you could do that I would
literally follow him or wherever he went
I was right behind him hey remember when
you asked me if it was bullying yet I
didn't know really I would say that this
is definitely stuck
this is shocking this is talking about
it okay
um you didn't mean harm I feel like
stalking has an intention I was so
scared of not doing a good job and not
knowing where he was I came from a good
place so I literally one day
one day we were filming at a hotel and I
followed him to his hotel room
and he turned around and he said Chase
you have to stop stalking me he did he
he did
um
and so then after that
then like next day we were filming at
like uh
um
I don't know location and he had his
trailer and I I knocked on the doors
like five minutes and I didn't want him
to think I was stalking him but I still
had to walk you and be like okay Larry's
heading to set you know I still had to
know and there was a bush
and I stood behind
the bush
as to not seem like a stalker yeah and
Larry got out of his trailer
he walked right past the bush did he see
me yes he did
and we just
like we just looked at each other just
how's this not in the [__] is this in an
episode
and he and I wish I had done something
like oh there's my phone you didn't say
anything no we just looked at each other
we just locked eyes as I was standing
behind a bush
okay now
um oh God meanwhile I was starting to do
stand up again
um because I just wanted my life to be
simple I was like I'm gonna PA during
the day and you stand up at night and
like that's what my life is I'm not
going to be doing a hundred million
things
um
and
so I was doing like which peeing is like
6 a.m to 11 p.m like it's a terrible yes
I was a PA for a while it's a grind hard
to do stand-up that's a 24-hour shifts
is a PA year yeah so
um they start I never told them I did
comedy I didn't want them to think I was
peeing just to like be on the show or
something but it came out like I had to
leave early I was doing like a stand-up
competition
and I had to leave early so I told them
and I won the competition good for you
thank you so I told the ads just to let
them make them feel better about me
leaving early I was like just you know I
won thank you so much
and then news spread that I was a
stand-up and uh
Adam the A.D took my hand and like
walked me to the director to Larry to
everyone Chase does stand up she won
blah blah blah and when Adam told Larry
I was standing in front of Larry and um
he said Chase just won a stand-up
competition she's really funny blah blah
and there's a picture someone took a
picture of Larry finding out that I do
stand up
and it's uh it's a look of concern like
he is so concerned
because I can't have one single
conversation with him I'm like so
awkward around him behind bushes yeah
like he's like and he goes you
you do stand up and he was so just
shocked and floored and
um I was like yeah he's like are you
good and I was like I guess and he was
like just uh
just don't talk about me in your set and
I was like okay got it and that was his
advice for my stand-up
so
it's like just um
so anyways they found out I did stand up
and then during the pandemic when they
were filming again I was able to go back
because touring had stopped
and
um again they were just like
they knew that at this point like stand
up is what I was doing and this newest
season that they're filming now they
gave me a part on the show hell yeah all
right did they and apparently they told
me when uh the stalker PA no oh God I
wish you were I wish you were to be so
funny like this girl's following me
everywhere
Lynn apparently like the the director's
assistant told me that when they pitched
me in the room to Larry to be the part
that I was cast in apparently he was
like ah
um but on set like during after each
take I was like how was that Larry how
am I doing and he was giving me notes
okay good all right I mean we have a
like he didn't sit in silence for that
no no he was like actually giving me
like pointers and notes he's like do it
this way and I liked that but don't do
it that like he was it was really cool
it was like a incredible like full
circle yeah good yeah that's look listen
that's a perfect way to end this episode
I can't thank you enough for coming on
and sharing humiliating moments look I
like these episodes I know everybody
worries about an episode like this like
it's not it doesn't measure up to I told
you before it recorded I I sit across
from people every week
and I hear things where I'm like what
the [__] am I bitching about you know
what I mean it is a prospective uh check
but but this is so good because it
explains so much about people and so
much we're so vulnerable at that age so
I'm gonna ask you now because uh you're
a first time here but that High School
pocket is a tough [__] Gauntlet it
just is there's so much going on so what
advice would you give to your 16 year
old self
I love this question I love that you ask
this I thought about it before and like
my advice was like keep your YouTube
channel because
I had one they were like emailing me do
you want to get paid for your videos and
I was like No And I like stopped doing
it can you imagine if I kept that going
anyways
I think my real advice would be like
you're going to
get a lot of advice from a lot of
different people soon
and instead of just doing that
really
ask yourself if that's what you want
Journal about it meditate and get clear
on what you want before you take advice
from other people who think they're
helping
but
you have to go with your gut and what
you want guts forever that's the I wish
I had learned that a lot younger I
learned it and I wish I listened to it
all the time I still sometimes like nope
my brain knows better and it doesn't it
never does yeah I know well thank you
for coming on I really appreciate it
this was a fun episode and um will you
plug and promote everything again please
okay
Chase underscore O'Donnell on Instagram
people pleaser on YouTube and well I
guess my tick tocks Chase underscore
Elaine if if you're a tick talker and
that's it Chase o'donnell.com all right
go see Chase live as always I am Ryan
sickler Ryan sickler on all social
mediarize sickler.com we'll talk to you
all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]